in that I am going to have to let you go
first
what why
well theft
stealing
stealing
what am I supposed to have stolen
Post-it notes
Post-it notes yeah what are those worth
like 50 cents
yeah you steal a thousand Post-it notes
at 50 cents a piece and you know you've
made a profit margin you know go run us
out of business Pam are you serious
yeah
um I can't believe this I mean I've
never even stolen as much as a paper
clip and now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
We're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh did I just clean
out your desk I'm sorry
foreign
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around see okay he was in on it he was
my accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were showing the new guy
around kind of kind of giving him the
feel of the place
so
[ __ ] you God you were we totally got you
you're a jerk
I don't know about that
what is
foreign
good night Jim hi Michael where are you
going
oh grab a drink I think
with us
I am I probably should have told you I
don't need a ride now because Jim can
take me home after so you're off the
hook okay great off the hook excellent
okay cool I got this all right have fun
don't drink and drive
take it easy good night you too have a
good night yo yeah
you sold a lot so
let's look here
oh
this is where I fell in love with you
and this is where I ask you to marry me
it started
laughs
Holly black
marrying me will you be
coming
he will I
[Applause]
okay see you guys uh on Monday
what about the surprise oh yes
exactly thank you Angela for reminding
me
terrific
um before I tell everybody what the big
surprise is would you like to tell me
what you think the big surprise is
we all think you don't have a surprise
all right I have some news for you
there is a big surprise
and
here it is here we go and
the big surprise is
drumroll
[Music]
when I am backed into a corner that is
when I come alive
see I learned improv from the greats
like um
Drew Carey and Ryan Stiles
[Music]
this
oh my God something's happening
nine million 986
000 minutes we actually sat down and did
the math
986
000 minutes that's how many minutes that
you've worked here in costumes and
impressions in meetings in cups of
coffee for birthdays more meetings and
email forwards you made us read 986
000 minutes
that's like watching Die Hard 80 000
times you hit me with your car you help
me get off drugs I watch you when you
sleep I forgive you for kissing me
remember to come
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's up
what's up
what's up
what
nothing
okay all right see you later all right
take care so I mean to tell you I want
to take you out for lunch for your last
day oh what do you think tomorrow lunch
you and me okay
you're not leaving tomorrow
you're leaving today right
Maybe
wow so that's it huh just
four o'clock and you are gone for good
why am I so sad
am I doing the wrong thing
absolutely not
it's just that sometimes goodbyes are a
[ __ ]
foreign
goodbye stink
okay all right so
James Halpert
you started with this company
as a fine young man you know what I
think we should do
I think we should just say the goodbyes
for tomorrow at lunch
oh
okay
and then tomorrow
I can tell you
what a great boss you turned out to be
best boss I ever had